Dishonored 2 is out this week and
needless to say tam is pretty excited
Oscar actually hates Lucy Lucy rights
over watch an affection firstly road hog
and may is supposed to be together and
secondly get me that Tamar goes commando
for three out of five days in a world I
like the freedom dammit anyway turns out
that along with the awesome gameplay
beautiful setting and the greatest NPC
chatter ever written out to be gather
for whiskey and cigars tonight never
doubt it it's casted totally rivals most
blockbuster movies so we just wanted to
they've actually upped the ante adding
rosario Dawson Sam Rockwell and Pedro
Pascal to the mix which got us thinking
so here's six other celebs that totally
snuck into our favorite video games
mmm I was a birdie I yes I would dear is
that you my dear husband as I mentioned
a solid probably had the most
high-profile video game voice cast since
50 cent blood on the sand pit Girl chloë
grace moretz as Emily called w'en
Wormtongue Brad Dourif as Piero and
Cersei Lannister as Calista colonel but
probably the biggest name on the list is
the Academy award-winning friends cameo
Queen dammit Janet it's Susan Sarandon
they say he's in league with the
outsider and that he won't rest until
everyone in dunwall is Ted game director
Harvey Smith said we had two people that
we would absolutely love to play that
character and she was the one who
responded Jesus if Sarandon was the one
who said yes was the other one like
Meryl Streep actually I'd play that
anyway it turns out Sarandon was the
perfect choice to play granny rags the
creepy blind lady who lives on the
streets of John Wall after a fall from
grace which was partly spurred on by the
fact that she dabbled in black magic
killed her husband and used his bones to
make those runes and bone charms that
you have to collect in the game but I
digress my favorite bit about granny
rags wasn't that she cared for animals
although she was a welfare activist who
just wanted to clean up the streets it
was actually had her own theme tune that
was really bloody catchy
they go
Idris Elba is East London's hottest
Hollywood export since Alfred Hitchcock
or as I like to call him hichi you might
know him as stringer Bell in the wire
Luther in Luther Heimdall in Marvel's
MCU or more recently as the voice of
Shere Khan in Jon Favreau's the jungle
book but did you know Idris Elba was
also in call of duty modern warfare 3 he
voiced truck one of the members of Delta
Force what do you mean you don't
remember him he was right by your side
during the whole game he even sacrificed
himself to save you and Captain Price
during the fight against Makarov he died
for you ok fine Idris Elba's role in
modern warfare 3 wasn't exactly
memorable he had lines such as got some
casualties here it's alex team and i
need an evac three casualties and then a
sad story told in three acts Elba says
he caught the gig because Infinity Ward
were fans yeah we're sure money and
marketing potential wasn't at all a
factor but to his credit he says he's a
keen gamer and a fan of the series it's
just a shame that he wasn't given a more
interesting character and let's all be
honest his talents was severely
underused I mean watch this clip of him
talking about truck it's like he's been
shown a picture of a generic soldier and
told to improvise a backstory ok dressed
what's his name truck cool cool Tommy
what's he like you know a real sort of
straightforward guy straightforward I
like it not too much to think about
point shoot excellent excellent so
what's he like on a night out stand-up
guy but they're all stand up guys when
he's a bit more straight down the line
he looks well and what about in battle
is a you know tough character tough
competing brilliant I love cookies put
him in the game lads sorry
who is this they give Deek back in 2012
Emma Stone was Fuhrman on the rise after
star turns in movies like easy a and
zombieland the only logical next step
would be to appear in an open world
action-adventure video game and so she
appeared in Sleeping Dogs appearing as
an American tourist / blog writer / kung
fu fan Amy Cartwright you take her on
two dates which lasts all of 10 minutes
in actual gameplay in one of which you
take on a brief tour of Hong Kong
culminating in an awkward run-in with
your old kung fu teacher on the other
you basically become an Instagram
husband while she poses for pictures for
a blog come on way jay-z can do it from
Beyonce you can do it too but alas
despite being all over the cash reveal
trailer she's actually barely in the
game which is a shame but it definitely
did wonders for her career before she
became the oscar-nominated Emma Stone
she was Best Performance by a human
female VFX award-nominated Emma Stone
seriously you know you're really sweet
but now's not the right now
what what's up guys Neil Patrick Harris
may be most famous for being a tiny
doctor and popularizing a slightly
irritating catchphrase it's gonna be
legendary be legendary to be legendary
it's gonna be legend wait for it but to
me he will always be called Jenkins
shooting bugs in starship troopers or
one of the most annoying boss fights
insane throat to DJ veteran child is a
lieutenant in the gang the sons of
samedi as well as a triple platinum DJ
radio host and drug dealer which
couldn't really be further from the
charming chap behind the character the
character returns as a simulation in
saints row 4 where you pretty much have
to pay the same annoying boss fight but
it's hard to stay angry at him with
those dulcet tones yeah like that's
gonna happen it's a shame we don't see
mr. Pete Harris in more video games I
could totally see him as a mild-mannered
scientist in the next Mass Effect it
would be legend wait for it and I hope
you're not lactose intolerant because
this next part is going to contain dairy
go legendary hello there traveling all
alone in these treacherous times
Peter Serafinowicz who you may know as
Darth strawberry from Star Wars Episode
one is a huge fan of Dark Souls in his
own words while people were getting
hooked on Breaking Bad his drug of
choice was from software's dark fantasy
RPG clearly a man of refined gaming
tastes it's it's just the most enjoyable
experience I've had playing video games
due to the point that it's it's ruined
other video games for me I imagine how
happy his little face must have been
when from software asked him to be in
the sequel in Dark Souls 2 he plays
mild-mannered pay a treasure hunt other
on the surface seems nice enough but
keeps sending the player into deadly
traps it turns out that he's a bit of a
trickster that walked the line between
friend and foe Serafina which does a
great job of sounding friendly but also
giving all his lines of sinister
undertone thank you very much I will
return the favor one day Serafina is did
a great job in Dark Souls 2 and
personally I'd like to see him do more
video game work he's clearly got a knack
for it huh he could be an act to still
knackered
while the fable franchise certainly had
its foibles it still remains one of my
all-time favorite gaming series the
eccentric world the monsters the quests
and the wonderful characters who are
apparently voiced by nearly every bloody
British actor there is John Cleese as
Jasper yuva new mask you exciting mix of
daring and dashing Michael Fassbender is
Logan this is my Albion stephen fry is
reaver these pitiful men are not a patch
on my old blood stone island sir ben
kingsley a Sabine I am Sabine elder of
the dweller tribe Simon Pegg has been
fed oh it's like being hit by a frozen
sock and Zoe Wanamaker as Theresa Sabine
is a good man all wonderful talented
actors that lend their voices of the
fabulous world of fable create a kind of
virtual West Country feel the warmth at
some of these actors lent their roles as
well as the dread the others portrayed
created a world and a cast of characters
that I spent dozens of hours getting
lost in in a perfect world maybe would
get a fable for starring such talent as
I'd know maybe Benedict Cumberbatch
Karen Gillan John boyega such a shame
the third one was such a chicken kicker
so there we are six a list celebs that
totally snuck into our favorite video
games but more videos like this one make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to gamespot
you'll see you next week